[Music]
jazz jennings is putting herself
before anybody else it's honestly so
important to me
the 20 year old youtube star is gracing
the cover of variety's power of pride
issue
opening up about her journey being
transgender and why she had to take a
break from her reality series
i am jazz which took an extended hiatus
in 2019
i just don't know if i'm ready to put
myself in that situation where
there is that men's pressure to succeed
you know between
graduating high school putting this drag
show together
and preparing for college i feel like
there's a
50 pound weight weighing on my shoulder
jazz opened up about taking time away
from the show explaining quote
i needed that break for my mental health
and wellness honestly but i have had
that time to really use self-care to
boost myself up and evolve and grow as a
person
i still have so much more to go but i
just feel like i'm moving in the right
direction
i was able to be my authentic self and
now today
i'm the girl you see standing here the
reality star also revealed that fans can
rest
easy announcing that season 7 of i am
jazz is underway
and i am ecstatic to announce that yes
there is going to be a season 7
of i'm jazz i am so thrilled i am
so ecstatic to share the rest of my
adventure my journey of life with you
all
and hopefully it could continue being an
educational experience where by sharing
my story
teach you all how to be loving embracing
and compassionate towards not just trans
people but
all people who have differences having
the opportunity to share her experience
being transgender
is a similar sentiment josh shared with
e.t in 2019.
here we are now five seasons later and
honestly i have no regrets
seeing how the show is able to really
make a difference in this world and help
people become more aware about
transgender issues
is just so important to me and obviously
being transgender all i want is to
create more visibility
and awareness on this topic so i'm proud
that my family has been able to do that
at the age of five jazz was diagnosed
with gender dysmorphia
making her one of the youngest people in
the public eye to be identified as
transgender
when it comes to her cultural impact she
says i was learning that there were a
lot of other kids like me out there who
can relate to me
and who saw me and learned more about
themselves through seeing me
and my experience once i learned about
it in that way
i was like okay that's pretty cool i
think in this day and age it's
more common to hear about someone being
transgender or lgbtq
questioning their gender identity and i
think that's so important because we
have all of this visibility all of these
people sharing their stories and it
allows
people to gain that knowledge and
experience and learn about what it means
to be trans so they can be better
equipped to accept those individuals
and as for her work as a trans advocate
jazz says she has no intention of
slowing down
my dream for the future is that i can
continue
making a difference in the world it's
honestly so important to me to be able
to create change because i feel like
this world needs a lot of change and
being able to play my part in this big
movement of making a difference is just
so important to me and i want to be able
to continue spreading my message to
humanity that we just all need to be our
authentic selves and not care what other
people think
all that matters is self-perception as
long as you love and value yourself
then it doesn't matter what anyone else
[Music]
says